hey guys how's it going this is going to
be a really just super casual super
laid-back question answer ask IJ I'm
gonna tell you why because I actually
was not able to bring myself to leave
this portion of my desk to go over to
this portion of the room to shoot this
video because this is where destiny is
this is basically where I've been
spending the past several days of my
life playing this game and I've been
having so much fun like actually way too
much fun
I said this in one of my gaming videos
are recorded it's kind of disgusting Cal
do I sit here and not have to be able to
get up if I have to go to the bathroom
do I go to the bathroom on myself it was
a thought that I had and that's when I
knew I had to go right onto your
questions it has been a really eventful
week with all of the iPhone 6
announcements and all of the craziness
that surrounds that time of the year
something that I've actually really
enjoyed reading is the comments the
iPhone and the Android users just
battling it out everyone's saying that
oh my gosh my Nexus in my Samsung is
that better technology than your iPhone
currently has this being released now
something that I think people are
forgetting is it's not necessarily about
the technology in the phone
it is the operating system it's the same
exact thing that Mac and PC people have
been battling it's an operating system
essentially that is what people are
buying into they're also buying into the
cult of the Mac I have been called an
Apple she just hurting my way through
life eating the Apple fangirl that I am
I am I guess what you know what honestly
I'm getting sick of their crap it's like
we get it Apple your Apple yeah we freak
and get it but guess what I just want to
buy the freaking phone I actually had a
post written up about how angry I was at
Apple and how disgusted I was I'm sick
of it I'm sick of having to wait up for
your stupid pre-orders at this point in
time you know how many iPhones you need
to make you know the demand I don't want
a freaking wait just let's let's cut the
crap because honestly people are gonna
get sick of it and I am your biggest fan
and I'm getting sick of it but anyway
moving on to the questions shall we
Sean wants to know where would I like to
travel that I haven't been before it's
crazy but I've never been tossed rally
and that is one place that I want to go
more than anything also what I really to
Greece too so there's a lot of places on
my to travel list but Australia I've got
to get there a lot of you guys are from
Australia I have a lot of friends there
it's definitely a destination that I
have to I have to get to Steve wants to
know who I'm wearing and it's so funny
that you asked that Steve because I am
actually wearing a t-shirt with a fox in
the pocket I actually ended up getting
this t-shirt when I was looking for a
dress and that always happens I'm
looking for something fancy for an event
and I end up buying either something
camo or a stupid t-shirt that I don't
need but this was honest it had had to
be mine it was beautiful oh the Fox say
God it will never get old David wants to
know if Jenna has found an apartment and
she actually has she was supposed to be
in this video so Jenna have you found an
apartment
yeah just see I found Horace Oh Sarah
wants a new one I'm getting the iPhone 6
I don't actually know when I'm getting
it because when i pre-ordered I stayed
up all the reeking night trying to order
the iPhone six-plus and right now as its
shipping at the beginning of October so
Apple if you're gonna say that the
phones available on September 19th why
don't you make the phone actually
available on September 19th instead of
[__] us around like you always do
sick of it the girl with the freaking
eye in front of her name is sick of it I
wish I could delete it anyway hold on a
phone call on my iPhone 6 plus plus plus
plus hello hi yeah it's really good to
hear from you yeah I'll hold on datato
switch hands because my phone is so big
I can't I had a I use you hands um yeah
I will I'll meet you I'll meet you at
the Apple Store uh-huh all right will
you have a nice day uh-huh goodbye Alex
says congratulations about two million
subscribers and I actually didn't even
make a video about this because I was so
pumped up about the freaking iPhone I am
NOT one that really likes to celebrate
milestones or tell people to go
subscribe or even really look at numbers
because it could be something that you
get so caught up in and you get so
caught up in like oh no so-and-so has
passed me and the subscription model how
it used to be you guys don't actually
see the videos in your feed like you
used to which it kind of sucks because
it's like we have two million
subscribers some people have 30 million
subscribers and that ratio of
subscribers to views does not match up
it just it just doesn't which is
unfortunate because a lot of you guys
have subscribed and you don't actually
ever see videos from your favorite
youtubers in your subscription feed at
all I mean people will sweet
like to see why haven't you posted a
videos like uh I posted one this morning
why didn't you see it I don't understand
but I am so honored to be able to make
videos for you guys and to connect with
you guys on not only YouTube at Facebook
and Twitter and Instagram and Vine and
and every social media website good is
possibly out there that you guys use I
use the most importantly is getting to
meet you guys in person is the coolest
thing ever going to VidCon is going to
playlist going to vlogger fairs going to
these things and getting to meet you
guys and give you a hug and just like
see that you're real people it kind of
just it really puts everything into
perspective it's like you guys are real
you are real humans you commenting I
have met some of you I've met many of
you guys and it's I don't know it's
awesome and I love you guys and I just I
I'm gonna start crying now I'm a little
emotional so now my glasses are smudgy
why you gotta be so smudgy and really
when it comes down to is you guys are
awesome and I want you all to just
strive to do what you want to do in life
there will be hurdles there will be
challenges but I'm just remembering back
to when my mom was like okay just seeing
what are you gonna do for a job I was
like I don't know I'm gonna figure it
out as I'm like crossing my fingers
slaving away doing crazy projects online
just to try to get enough money to pay
my rent and buy Starbucks that is
something no anybody ever asks me about
mistakes that I've made in my life it's
probably going to Starbucks and buying
coffee instead of paying my rent when I
first started doing this stuff I'm not
even kidding you I was scraping up
quarters from everywhere that I could
possibly find
I was actually digging into my couch
cushions hoping that I could find
something not to pay rent which I
probably should have been paying my rent
with but I made my roommate we would go
get coffee we could go to Starbucks sit
there and be like what are we doing with
our lives I'm like I don't know I still
sometimes so that day just sit back and
think like what am i doing what are we
all doing or making videos
we're not like curing cancer or anything
that's why it's like people who think
just because you have a lot of
subscribers like you're entitled to
doing things like we're not like
honestly we're making videos this is fun
it's entertainment I'm just happy to
have you guys as friends it's so funny
whenever I travel the best part about it
is meeting you guys in the airport
seeing you guys on the street or in
random cities or random countries and it
kind of blows my mind about how huge
this internet thing is and how you guys
have changed so many people's lives so
just stay awesome stay cool let's go on
to the next question I don't even know
what I've been saying for the past
couple of minutes jaqen nuggets or
chicken strips I'm gonna go with chicken
strips because chicken nuggets are
smaller but you usually get more chicken
nuggets but with the chicken strips you
get to just kind of stab them with your
fork or pick them up and just have
several bites where's the chicken nugget
is more like a one or two bite I like to
have multiple bites
Jerell wants to know what book I'm gonna
recommend for audible this month I
actually just downloaded Joan Rivers
diary of a mad diva from my audible book
this month and I'm so excited because I
had a chance to work with Joan and I got
to meet her and she's one of those
people who yes she may be crazy you may
see this crazy character of a person
that comes out online or in videos or
shows but she was so talented and so
with it it blew my mind that I'm sitting
there having a conversation with this
woman and she knows more about life than
anyone I've ever met she was so witty so
quick with and I would say something and
she would immediately have a comeback
I'm like I have nothing to say to you
like you are brilliant
you were just uh it just is so
heartbreaking I honestly was so shocked
when I found out she had passed away and
I'd been following it so closely online
and it really is just such a tragic loss
because she has so many years left and
Joan I love you I wish that I could have
done more projects with this woman I
mean oh God she's amazing you guys want
to watch that video also put a link in
the description where you guys can watch
my in bed with Joan episode she I love
her it's so sad it's one of those things
where you guys never know what tomorrow
will bring so make the best of every day
that you've got and if you guys now I
got to go into my schpeel
of my free audiobook which is so cool
because audible has also changed my
traveling life
cuz I love to read when I start reading
a book reading makes me so tired it is
one of those things that if I need to
fall asleep I will start reading a book
but audible I'm actually able to listen
to books and comprehend it some people
learn things differently I am one of
those people that I read something I
don't know what I just read at all I'll
be like I'm sorry I didn't comprehend it
which is probably why it's so terrible
in school oh yeah I read those several
chapters for whatever class and then I
got to take a test on it I don't know
what I read if you guys want to get your
free audio book you can go to allcom
slash iJustine audible what did I say
slurring my speech I've been playing a
spending away too much time in front of
the Xbox audible.com slash iJustine get
your free book definitely if you can
check out diary of a mad diva I actually
haven't started listening to it yet but
I'm gonna be traveling soon so that's
gonna be my book of choice for next
month probably gonna be really sad like
listening to Joan read the book to me I
don't even know if I'll be able to even
make it through it I'm gonna go edit
this video did I even have any other
questions
did you guys ask me I don't even know
this is a very strange video I've just
been I don't know I've had a lot of my
mind and um I'm so even though I make
videos all the time sometimes it's very
hard for me to convey actually what I
want to say to you guys but the bottom
line is I love you you guys are amazing
and if you ever think that there's
something that you can't do it's not
true you can do anything you want look
you know
I don't oh I'll see you guys later hope
you guys have an excellent day
do everything else oh say I don't know
I'm gonna go play destiny now after
added in pusses video bye
what does the Fox say let me out of his
pocket he say he's I don't wanna be in
here anymore I don't want to be in here